well our guest today is praised as the
punk rock Julia Child of the net
generation TV chef and comedian Nadia G
joins us on this episode of film courage
infusing rock and roll amazing culinary
skills and really cool outfits Nadia
jeez bitchin kitchen debuted in 2007 as
a three-minute mobile cooking show with
smashing success the show quickly gained
the attention of mainstream broadcast
media giving way to the 2010 bitchin
kitchen premiere on food and lifestyle
entertainment brand to transition from
web to television very cool in October
2010 bitchin kitchen made its American
debut on The Cooking Channel in addition
Nadia's best-selling book bitchin
kitchen cookbook rock your kitchen and
let the boys clean up the mess was
released in 2009 I like that and I know
you love that little tiger in there what
I was making some of the chapters
include one-night-stand breakfast okay
um p.m. escapades and broke ass dishes
Nadia's bitchin kitchen has not only
infused the Food Network and Cooking
Channel with a bad girl brand of humor
and know-how but the whole bitching DIY
approach is introduced to viewers on
Nadia site in lifestyle TV where
you'll find cool kitchen gear t-shirts
videos and bitching culture please
welcome to film courage via telephone
the lovely Nadia G hello Nadia you know
we're excited ourselves and we just we
just want to sort of you know relay that
to our audience listening out today we
can look thank you to be here we're
excited to have you are our first
question goes to our listeners do you
love the cook what is your go-to dish if
you were trying to impress someone
special what what meal would you cook
please send us a tweet with the hashtag
film courage and can you also please add
at bitchin kitchen maybe maybe not eat
yourself will sort of respond and give
you some pointers you know if you want
to follow along the conversation online
you can go to tweet chat com just type
in the hashtag film courage and for
those of you not on Twitter you're
welcome to reach out to us on Facebook
or
war film cars.com well again thank you
Nadia for joining us today we've been
looking forward to this interview for a
very long time so very excited now I
understand you grew up is it
saint-léonard it's a conservative
borough of a Montreal Quebec yeah that's
right it's an Italian borough it's uh
you know I mean it's what's really
interesting is that when we launched the
show in the States a lot of people like
what's that accent is it Brooklyn is it
New Jersey and we're like no it's
actually saint-léonard and what's
interesting about this there's a lot of
second-generation Italians insanely and
argue no parents fresh off the boat the
kids are born it's a lot of us speak
Italian angio bottle italiana and go
today so uh um yeah yeah it's so you
know there's a really interesting
peculiar accent in saint-léonard and in
fact it even goes beyond the accent and
it's almost like its own freakin
language and in the back of my cookbook
you'll find you know a glossary of terms
if you will for all the kind of stuff
that we say also we have Web Clips
called word of the day which help which
help people figure out what the hell I'm
talking about with words like
discombobulated or me or anyway so it's
it's interesting stuff that's really
cool yeah i know you have t-shirts too i
growing up in a town that's conservative
for myself I grew up in something like
that as well and I was into punk rock
and rock and roll and you get treated a
little differently especially if you're
a girl was this the case for you oh man
you better believe it it was it was
crazy you know and not to mention you
know back back in the day the high
school I went to was Catholic now
they've kind of separated church and
state when it comes to education but you
know it was definitely a conservative
mentality and you know I realized that a
very young age that you know it wasn't
for me the the white picket fence and
suburban you know kind of polite
lifestyle I had my own vision of who I
wanted to be and where I wanted to go
and it certainly wasn't accepted in
faintly in her and like you said is
especially being a girl you know people
didn't like it you know and I mean I
shape man was it was it was quite crazy
you know shaved head a bunch of tattoos
you don't see that insanely in art you
know you know certainly not in the in
the early 90s still to this day quite
frankly you know yeah I think it scares
people they kind of they don't know
where to categorize you it freaks people
out a little bit now there are millions
of people who dream of making it in
entertainment and you know there's so
few who do it's a tough thing so first
off where does your work ethic come from
and what do you think separates you from
the many who have come short on their
dreams oh wow you know that that's a
really great question and I would have
to say you know when I was a teenager I
kind of you know it all ties in together
I kind of rebelled against the
mainstream but while doing that I had to
say to myself well what's worth living
for like what excites me and and that's
where entertainment came in and and what
was so wonderful about you know the
whatever those the late 90s early two
thousand one internet was around so you
know if you have a dream you can really
materialize it online you don't have to
wait for someone to green-light your
project and it kind of gives you that
instant satisfaction of putting up a
site you know you see people are
watching your videos you get some kind
of comment response so even though
you're not making it at the big time you
still feel like you're moving ahead and
people are seeing you know your your
project and responding to it now in
terms of work ethic I mean I guess I'm
just a workhorse you know and like they
say they say you know you love what
you're too it doesn't feel like work now
sometimes but sometimes really does feel
like working there is a lot of hard work
involved I gotta say that you know we
launched our show on Cooking Channel
last last fall and I mean prior to that
I mean I've been doing you know videos
online and working on on an
entertainment project since 2001 so
oh you know calculate that paycheck this
is basically no money and investing all
your time and all your energy for you
know almost ten years we are on the line
with host of bitchin kitchen Nadia G and
we'd like to talk a little bit more
about your beginnings Nadia but before
we do we'd like to talk about your life
right now you mentioned the cooking
channel can you sort of paint a picture
for us how many people do you have on
your team right now that that help you
produce bitchin kitchen you know what
what is your kitchen studio like in your
office space can you just sort of paint
the picture for us sure sure and I'll
just give you a give you a comparative
so when we first started this project it
was me and my partner sitting across
from each other on one desk working
about 12 to 16 hours a day seven days a
week and now I would say we have a
dedicated web team we have an office
with our web team which has about five
employees and then we have our
production team when we when we produce
the TV show i would say that we're about
20 when it's time to shoot the TV series
and and then there's myself who works
from my home office you know writing the
scripts and kind of overseeing the
social media strategy and and all those
good things designing merch so i would
say you know our team our core team is
about you know under 10 people and when
it's time to go into production you're
looking at about you know 20-plus okay
and how is this sort of the studio you
know your kitchen in your office space
how has that changed oh man i'll give
you another comparative on that one
basically when we first started a
bitchin kitchen as a web series i had a
dressing room made of cardboard and my
crew was was so nice to me that they
even took the time to draw a crappy star
on a loose leaf and right Nadia G on it
impact that to the cardboard dressing
room and now I mean we have you know we
have our own studio we built our
own studio so it's about 2,000 square
feet you know really wild kitchen design
gorgeous you know a retro-looking fridge
and stove bright cherry red with chrome
you know a custom countertop but the
thing is you know is that I have a lot
of crafty people on my crew and and
together we have a lot of vision and we
kind of put it down on paper and make it
happen you know not everything has to
cost a million dollars if you're willing
to get your hands dirty you can make
things look pretty damn fine on a
limited budget let's go back to early
two thousand or two thousand one now you
did these web videos first off there's
really none of them circulating out
there I haven't found any are they still
online well I'll tell you one of the
videos that we redid is I used to do a
lot of comedy song so I did this song
called I'm never drinking like that
again and it was such an awesome
experience to be able to take that song
and redo it for the TV show it appears
actually in rehab recipes the whole last
act is is devoted to a music video which
is which is super cool definitely the
first music video to ever air in a
cooking show I'd say okay very cool I
love that idea rehab recipes so yeah so
tell us about these videos I mean did
you have sort of this specific purpose
of using the internet to eventually get
yourself on TV or was just a fun thing
you were doing with friends you wanted
to be creative no there was always the
purpose for it to be multi platform and
and get on TV you know I think I think
that's important and one of the things
that I did back then and that we still
did with bitchin kitchen is that when we
created a webisodes you kind of you got
it you got to think of them in terms of
television production value again on a
budget and figure out how to do that but
you know some people kind of believe
that you know or at least a few years
ago now it's a little different that you
know web enter
janeman can be crappier where the edits
can be less tight the fact of the matter
is is that if you're aiming for TV you
gotta shoot stuff that looks TV worthy
that the fact is people don't have much
imagination you know especially when
you're pitching a project they don't
have time imagination patience so you
got to be able to show them a product
that television worthy so they can
visualize the transition once you have
the idea for bitchin kitchen what when
did you know that this this could really
be something special like how how soon
before you before you realize well you
know one thing that that that clued me
in right away like when I tell people
the title is kind of like you know title
or elevator pitch everyone was really
really excited um you know I myself have
a lot of friends and in the biz here in
Montreal so we were passing around the
pitch document and just saw you know
people's faces light up and say wow you
know because at the end of the day that
the cooking space is one that was
generally vanilla and there really is a
real hunger parting the cheesy pun for
something a little bit more rock and
roll like it's not everybody that wants
to cook in the cart again and for me it
was also just a really you know I think
people really enjoyed the high concept
of it too like what's interesting is if
the show is truly a hybrid it's a
scripted comedy cooking show and there's
you know Alton Brown he kind of does his
thing it was very inspiring for me that
was one of the people that inspired me
for sure I said wow you know this guy's
doing something different with with the
cooking platform but but yeah I mean it
people had a great reaction straight
straight away it makes me wonder
especially because you do bring up you
know sort of the production value you
know you know you mentioned you don't
have to spend a million dollars but at
the same time there is money that needs
to be invested so how long before you
had the idea that you sort of went out I
either invested yourself or for found
investors for for sort of the this this
this rock and roll kitchen that you're
talking about
because you know the early videos that
we see that you have online me this this
is sort you know it's an imaginative you
know high quality production this isn't
like this isn't like you just showing up
and filming like in your grandmother's
kitchen yeah yeah that's right well you
know it basically like all the
experience that I had gained throughout
the years in terms of doing web video
was then applied to this project and
then when we passed the pitch document
around for this project airborne
entertainment which which does mobile
content and has a connection with
verizon beach house totally loved it and
we actually got an initial budget I
would see of about thirty thousand
dollars Canadian to produce 26 mobis
oats and you know what I did what I did
and I still do to this day is like I
reinvest all that money you know like
the mobile ad was thirty thousand
dollars we ended up spending the
equivalent of like 67 double is the
amount weather was not necessarily
physical cash but also prime investment
so it's like that old thing you know
quick cheap and good you know pick two
so if you don't if you don't have the
money you're gonna have to invest the
time
have these webisodes and then how does
it end up in the lap of the cooking
channel was there a contest or how did
this happen no we pitched you know we we
pitched Food Network Canada first and
they saw that it was a great success
online we had a tangible proof of
concept and and they went for it you
know and it was tough and let me tell
you because back in 10 in 2007 you know
while you know we had our webisode MOBA
soldier webisodes but we were
simultaneously you know trying to pitch
network we went down to LA and agents
down there love the show but they were
like listen man this business you know
you can't put this show on Food Network
because it's way too crazy and there's
comedy in it you can't put this show on
a comedy a network because there's food
in it and they were like basically you
guys are screwed like you have a reality
show concept for a reality show like man
what what reality show the reality is I
sit in front of my computer 15 hours a
day trying to get this business off the
ground doesn't make for exactly you know
a groundbreaking television here so we
stuck to our guns though you know and
like that was a real real hard moment
for us because they were like this show
is impossible to sell and you know but
we we stuck to it and and eventually the
tinies caught up with us you're going to
the mobile market I mean was that
something you were excited about it or
like was there something inside of you
where you like you know what this is I
am moving forward but the same time I
really want to be on television I mean
that did that did that fuel you at all
of course of course but you know back
then also I was so happy that someone
you know sometimes it's not the amount
of the paycheck but it's just like
finally getting someone to give you a
budget you know if you do that you know
gives you that feeling that you're on
the on the right track and definitely
heading in the right direction so
although you know I I obviously did feel
like wow I can't wait for this to be the
TV show
I still was was pretty stoked that
someone other than myself was willing to
invest time and money in this project
and I knew that this was going to be a
big stepping-stone and one thing that's
always interested me besides the
production aspect and the creative
aspect is marketing and man I know how
to make a mountain out of a molehill
this is one of the biggest skills you
need in this business you know sometimes
it's less about the quality of your
product and more about how you talk
about it look we all know the kind of
content that we see on TV or the people
that have risen to celebrity you know
it's a marketing machine it's not always
necessarily a hundred percent about the
the content itself so I knew that by
having you know mobis oats out there i
could have not only a proof of concept
but something to talk about and we would
answer all kinds of contents and
competition I mean we won we won
favorite movie favorite mobile comedy
series and you know this wasn't a huge
award it was a wave award but man do we
make noise about that you know we peeped
out Conan O'Brien we were touting not
left right and center Andy Cohen and
probably even though he was nominated
for a wave awards okay it's all about
it's all about you know just just
getting those awards and you know just
kind of using whatever you have to your
advantage at the moment you know it
sounds like you didn't rest on the fact
that you know that you had these these
mobile app episodes that you were going
to take this and use this as a way to
sort of leverage yourself and push
yourself further so how soon in the
process where you were releasing these
mobis ODEs you know how soon before you
begin pitching the networks and saying
look this is the quality of what I can
do for you well it started it started
pretty soon after I would see after we
won that wave award which was like a few
months into the launch of our of our
mobile series we contacted an
entertainment lawyer friend of ours
in LA and then you set up a bunch of
meetings with with agencies we ended up
getting hit pocketed by endeavor back in
the day but the climate wasn't ready at
the TV climate wasn't ready yet for four
bitchin kitchen for the reasons I
mentioned earlier and then while we were
you know being pitched in LA and seeing
that we weren't getting much response
and people were saying what you want to
do a reality show this company in Canada
this production company in Canada called
trikon gave us a call us and then we
heard about you and there's a big buzz
and you know we have a good relationship
with food network canada we've produced
hit shows for them can you you know can
you please let us pitch you or going and
meet with Food Network Canada we were
like oh I don't know you know so we
asked endeavour they thought it was okay
which are now never William horse and
they were like yeah sure Canada who so
you're like all right then you know
pitch in Canada and hold the old days
they made it happen you know they really
made it happen so in your infancy stage
you know was it sort of your attitude of
we're gonna we're gonna grow this thing
to be so big that that whoever's who in
TV they're going to have to sort of
they're going to take notice of what
we're doing was it was that part of your
sort of attitude and part of your
strategy oh absolutely man you know like
just bullish should see you just you
just one track minded and yes I you just
I said to myself this is you know we're
going to build the community and you
know just get that a real proof of
concept and just keep going at it until
people kind of have to say yes because a
you're not going away and be you're not
going away you were tuned to film
courage on la talk radio com we would
like to extend our gratitude to Peter on
limb who dazzles us with his generosity
as the only person who was donated twice
to phone courage what else can we say
about mr. peter ong limb huh he loves
supporting those in the indie film
community he's incredibly bright and
he's someone you should be connected
with find him on facebook at peter
limb and connect with him on twitter at
pol md i'm sorry at film pol and i
forgot the film part we're on the line
with Nadia G host of The Cooking
Channel's bitchin kitchen mention this
in this interview and we've seen it
elsewhere where you know you've put in
countless hours every day you know long
days 10 hour days 12 hour days 15 hour
days how often did you doubt that that
you would be in where you are now I mean
there were a few moments there's always
you know there's always a few moments
where you totally say to yourself man
what what am I doing here what's going
on but ultimately deep inside I always
knew that this was going to happen you
know and frankly if you don't have that
ninety-nine percent of the time you're
sure that it's going to happen for you
it's tough to make it happen honestly
because at times you got nothing but
sheer will the sheer you know the force
something into existence and you know I
always had you know people that that
helped encourage me along the way it's
so it's so important when things are bad
like a given example in a crappy studio
with a cardboard dressing room with no
air conditioning in four-inch heels
sniffing soup and singing it smells so
good take 52 you know it's like 60
degrees in the studio this time like
that you know you're like wow it's a
house phone line here but but no matter
how down i got like i said ninety-nine
percent of time I visualized this
happening I knew this was going to
happen I was going to make it happen and
and so it goes where does that what does
that self-assurance come from you know I
think it comes ultimately from from my
parents you know I was an only child
they always gave me a ton of attention
you know I say they allowed my
creativity to bloom as a kid the teenage
years was a different story
the core but you know the early years
are the important years and and my
family was always kind of treating me
like a rock star hmm interesting and so
you're picked up by Food Network Canada
how did they contact you and when they
did what kind of emotions were running
through you and what were you thinking
were you scared were you happy well then
I'll tell you you know that story of
Food Network Canada was really something
we had gotten word from from trikon that
they wanted to move ahead with the show
but you know nothing was signed on paper
yet you know if it takes forever to get
contracts actually signed you know in
fact you can have any a show on the air
for six episodes before a contract to
sign so it was taking a long time to
finally get everything finalized and
then what happened was this was that we
knew they were interested in a show and
then doesn't freaking canwest which is
the company that owns Food Network
Canada and global TV and like every
single practically every single TV
station Canada aren't they going
bankrupt so I'm saying to myself what
the hell finally I get my TV series and
the whole freakin what luck is dying the
deep you know that that the whole
industry is going bankrupt so we were
freaking out and we were running out of
money because we were basically living
off a Canadian grant telefilm for our
web our web series and website etc and
that money was starting to you know come
to come to an end and we had to let so
many people go and say listen you know
that the the show is still not happening
yet and you know the whole world is
crumbling and so mean Josh my partner
was sitting there were super depressed
working late at night and it's about
midnight and we get a call from one of
the guys that was was working with us
saying yeah Josh so what's up and
Johnson's like what what do you mean
what's up it's midnight I don't know
we're working the things up what are you
trying to say he's like yeah well I saw
in playback magazine that bitchin
kitchen got picked up on food
Canada who are like watch so we
eventually found out you know after
everybody else we were so happy I mean
you know crying and screaming for joy
and you know I mean it's really
emotional this business as you both know
and probably a lot of people listening
in like this is your life man it's not
it's not a career it's not a hobby this
is you this is it when your project
suffers you suffer it's your child I
mean we were we were we're like our baby
Harbor you know you know what what was
different Nadia you know about you know
when you're sort of up and running on
the on the Food Network Canada what was
different about being in that space as
the pose when you were launching these
webisodes what were were the tangible
factors that I guess that the network
you know Food Network Canada wanted to
be a part of what what did you have then
well you know it was great because we
you know we had a bigger budget so we
were able to you know flex our creative
muscles a little bit more as i mentioned
earlier you know we were able to shoot
like a you know take rehab recipes to
the next level and insert a music video
in there because with the web code you
only have three to five minutes so it's
like you know you gotta pick what you're
going to show you can't exactly devote
the whole thing to a music video so we
were super excited it was also kind of
scary I mean that you know that that
first time when your show launches and
you start here you know like people
start talking smack about you o mine
like you know I'm used to it whatever
rolls off my back I find out the
person's IP address so when they will
talk look like they're in manual you
know you you get it hits you hard you
know like so I mean salary what was
great was that we had a bigger budget
but we all said you know bigger pressure
like you really want it and you want it
to be great and this this is your chance
now you know because the thing with this
business as we all know it's like it's
all really nice when you
finally get green your show Greenland
but then your shoes gotta not get
canceled you know then you gotta do
numbers you got it you know you gotta
get renewed for a second season so that
the pressure the pressure continues
before the TV deal did you have any
sponsorship deals worked out like with
cookware companies knife outlets what
have you yeah sure I mean it was it was
all products only sponsorships and I
mean it was amazing you know the kind of
sponsorship and how minimal people were
like elmira stove works which which
creates those gorgeous vintage looking
fridge stove appliances etc Mandy
sponsored us from day one even even when
it was just even when it was just a web
series and like you're talking about you
know ten thousand dollars worth of
appliances so yeah we did have a
sponsorship our knives as well we still
use and we still stick to these people
to this day so this day there's only air
still works on our set there's kasumi
knives that I always use and you know
dem iron cookware etc so the a lot of
these sponsors that were there from the
beginning we definitely take along for
the ride how early in the game were you
engaged in social media I mean you're on
YouTube of course but I mean you have
this huge Facebook and Twitter following
how early did that come into play all
right from the beginning you know I'm
not Jenny to the intel core and the
minute social media came to the fore I
was there and there's nothing more
important than community online you know
it it's really the reason you know one
of the main reasons we have to show is
that there's there's so many people out
there that are engaged with this brand
and we you know we love engaging them
and talking to them as real people I
mean I really always owe it all to our
community and that's what I want to
follow up on Nadia so would you say that
you know sort of your presence on these
in social media on these platforms I
mean did that
have a direct impact or direct influence
in sort of helping you it def it
definitely did there's no question about
it no question about it a huge I mean
you you need to engage your audience and
it really is that that that proof of
concept it's like when you know a
network looks at that stuff and says wow
there's really a segment of the
population that's truly into this stuff
and that's what they need to know then
you know that you know you can't I I
don't think it's really possible to get
a show on TV without the social media
following you know unless you're an
a-lister or a blister you know you can't
exactly go up to the network and say a
and I have this great concept they need
proof and what is it what proof do they
need what are they looking for well I
think they're looking for a sizable
audience they're looking for an
engagement you know how how people are
how people are commenting on your brand
or you know the interaction you know
because it's one thing to have you know
let's say a thousand fans but none of
them are really doing anything on your
Facebook page and it's and it's a
stagnant you know you have to kind of
keep the conversation going and show
that there's you know that there's a
real back and forth and an active
interest in the brand or project and are
you still on social media yourself or do
you sort of delegate that to someone in
your crew on your team I mean do you
still take do still partake do you still
interact directly with your fans
absolutely I totally partake and but I
do have a crew that entertains our
community every day but I checked in
every day multiple times a day ok and
then how are you able to balance that
would sort of with other people doing it
and then you doing it how do i how do
how does one know that it is this this
is actually Nadia G that I'm talking to
oh great question we have we use our
initials so on facebook you know if it's
my community manager and it'll be
written eight
ki colon and then the comment opposed
whatnot and went it to me it's ng colon
and when it's Ella and so forth you know
we use the first letter of the first
name last name okay alright so the you
know everyone has that information and
and and also out of curiosity if let's
say Food Network Canada did not pick up
your show you know would you have been
able to keep doing what you were doing
or did you sort did you need TV to sort
of come in and partner with you you know
for you really to make all this happen
would you would you have been able to do
it without the support of what you have
now well we would have definitely
continued and we would have said you
know what we're gonna pitch again you
know but luckily one thing that helps a
lot being in Canada's they have a lot of
funding for the Arts and you were lucky
enough to get you know a grant you know
and we're talking big grunts here in
Canada it's not like 50 bucks and a cup
of coffee we're talking about like a
quarter of a million dollars half a
million dollars in some cases you can
apply for grants of a million dollars so
it's not you know it's not guarantee
that you're going to get those brands
but at least they're available to you
you know to keep the project alive I
mean if we would have not gotten got
grant from telefilm while we were
waiting for the TV show to come through
then we would have really been finished
mm-hmm and you have this great segment
called um get famous frittata which is a
two-part video and it's funny but it's
also very very true i mean it talks
about if you want to you know make a
name for yourself these are the things
you have to do and one of the things is
you know growing incredibly thick skin
you also say take 10 to 15 hours a day
to work at your craft for five to ten
years to make it happen very true so
going back to the beginning is this how
you were sort of managing both worlds
with these grants because I mean it must
be very hard to sort of pay the bills
and then also be at your computer this
entire time absolutely I would
definitely you know the the grandstand
and getting some
you know I designed websites and did a
lot of strategy and branding for other
brands as well so that helped pay the
bills and cost of being in this business
but yeah the grants were definitely a
huge part right and how did you learn
this website design and and why did you
have this as part of your set of skills
yeah well you know it's such an
important skill set to have you know was
the website design branding marketing
all really really necessary tools what
happened with that when I had you know
the idea to with some online
entertainment I would contract that
stuff out I never really liked what they
returned to me and it's super it cost me
a fortune it looked like crap you know
I'm an a-type personality i want you
know i notice if something is one pixel
off so I'm like screw this man i'm just
going to teach myself and what's so
awesome about the web is that you have
all these tutorials available to do you
can really do anything online and you
say you designed your current website
that's right i designed the the current
website I design a lot it I still to
this day all the rock this look that we
do where we feature all the the fashion
that I we're in a particular episode and
where to get it or where to get
something like it I love designing and
it's really a peaceful place for me you
know and it allows me to be like super
anal and just focus need it get
everything in line perfectly you know
you know we we have brought up a few
couple times here the bitchin kitchen
cookbook rock your kitchen and let the
boys clean up the mess and you wrote
this book while your show was still sort
of in the mobile internet forum so how
important was it was it for you to have
something tangible you know and I must
add you know everything we see from you
is also high quality so how important
was it to have something tangible and
high quality that was related to your
show and it's something that your fans
could own
it was it was a beautiful thing you know
and that was one of those lucky stories
that you know the publisher just came to
us they saw our web clips and our motor
souls and said wow this is a great
concert we want to do a cookbook I would
see 99 percent of the time that's not
what happened we're like all right well
that sounds great you know I designed
the cookbook myself as well so that was
a really interesting challenge because
prior to that I was doing all my design
work and 72 DPI which is basically web
it's a whole different world when you
get into you know high res imagery and
the photo shoots with a real challenge
you know but also really beautiful in a
lot of ways because you know the book
you can touch it it's not vapor it's not
pixels it also helped my family better
understand what the hell I was doing
because my friend was like well what you
doing in leaky stupid videos on the
internet you know he didn't you know
didn't get it they're not baby weren't
online so for them the cookbook was a
real opportunity to touch something ah
this is what naughty is doing and I'm
sure to not yet with where you are now
people have this perception like you
know what being on TV having a book and
a huge fan base is like living a party
lifestyle you know we see these videos
of you at these various food events and
and it just looks so fun but how much of
this how much of that perception is
really true that it is a party lifestyle
and how much of it is you may be by
yourself creating content and a lot of
hard work is it as sort of glamorous as
it looks you know I'm still waiting for
the big glamorous part you know i'm
kidding partially but yeah a lot of it i
would say a lot of it is still me
sitting from my computer you know
getting the work done thinking about the
next contest online you know designing
stuff you know thinking about you know
writing scripts and then you know at the
on occasion you get the opportunities to
really feel the rewards which I mean
like let's face it you know I'm gonna be
honest but you I'm in this business
because I wanted to get famous you know
I want a limo to come and pick you up
want to get kicked out of the VIP room
or something these are all things what
but but yeah I would say it's it's when
you finally have a moment to breathe
from all the hard work and step back and
look at this little empire that you've
created or this you can really say wow
you know this is this is awesome and you
you you feel you feel the reward but a
lot of the time when you're in the thick
of it you know you're still you're just
working your you're working your ass off
sure and you had talked about earlier
this new kind of pressure like in the
beginning it's a pressure to launch
things and then once you get things
going there's a new pressure to keep it
going so do you feel competition from
other cooking personalities or or people
that are out there does that does that
ever fuel you to kind of keep going that
competition I'm a very competitive
person that's for sure but what's what's
so fun about about the bitching brand is
that we're so unique and it's like there
is no competition right yeah it's very
unique and very catchy i love it what
are some of the misconceptions people
have about being famous or recognized
you know you mentioned earlier that
there can be detractors but what are
some of the the biggest misconceptions
well the biggest misconception and it
comes back to what you mentioned earlier
about sexism is that you know some some
people out there imagine that I'm like
some kind of Hostess I got hired by the
network and got offered some kind of you
know no man you know I worked my ass off
I write the scripts i co-produced this
series so I would say that's one of the
biggest ones and not just for me but for
a lot of people who have made it in the
entertainment industry that somehow they
were just so lucky and it just got
handed to them on a silver platter i
would say in some cases sure there's a
despotism in industry but most of the
time people work pretty damn hard for
what they got mm-hmm
yeah I agree and it sounds like you've
just done an amazing thing I mean you
learned the web design and all of that
and you just weren't just going to just
go the traditional route and pass out
headshots do you get ever go back home
and if so what do they say now go back
home yeah to see some of the people that
you went to high school with and and how
do they perceive you now ah you know I
don't really see much of the people I
went to high school with anymore one of
my my group I only have one friend that
I retained from high school Mary Martin
noe and she does all she chooses all the
music for our episodes which is really
cool you know i'm not i'm not really
friendly with with the people I went to
high school with that much you know they
didn't really accept me then and to this
day it's kind of like you know we're
just very different people there are a
few obviously that will come to the
launch parties and so on but besides
that it can suck it right right yeah I
remember Dave I think told me this great
story about Howard Stern you always tell
me that story how that the one bully of
Howard Stern guest came back to him
years later and Howard was just like
what you were my friend then yeah when I
really needed you ya know so why now
really you know and that's one of the
things that I talk about in the gets
beam is frittata webclip or even read it
that show for for the the TV show is if
you know is oh I forgot my line of
thinking I got all excited about being
like that famous frittata and cicadas
but yeah it's basically you know revenge
is a dish best served on television
right right i remember that part and
just as we wrap up here Nadia I noticed
that you just give these flawless
interviews was that always the case did
you kind of have to practice at doing
that and you just got more comfortable
or it was just always something you're
just comfortable speaking delivering
your message how did you kind of manage
to make that happen because you just do
such a flawless delivery
all the interviews that I've seen oh
thank you you know I mean I judge myself
hard on the on the interviews I give I
think a lot of people like I don't want
to see it I don't want to hear it I
guess you know the more you talk about
something the better you get at talking
about it is really what it comes down to
it and I really enjoy it you know and I
I enjoyed a lot i really enjoyed the
interviews that i'm doing now because
people are kind of familiarized with the
brand so it's not so much about you know
just talking about the basically
introducing what my show is i'm able to
get into the nitty-gritty of things i
really interest me like for example this
interview has been fantastic and you
know i've also had the opportunity to
talk at you know South by Southwest and
to do panels that are more industry
related so I'm really enjoying this this
next chapter if you will very cool
alright well thank you yes you've
enjoyed our time with you today
absolutely you know it's been great just
sitting back and just listening to how
you combine your craft your love for
cooking and how you intermesh intermesh
that with sort of your web skills your
creative skills your design skills
business branding you just everything
across the board I mean you're just the
the full package from start to finish
Nadia yeah thank you so much you know
and i just opened inspires people people
out there too and honestly where there's
a web there's a way oh you know grant
your grant you know like i said you if
you don't have the money you invest the
time II you know I really believe that
if you if you keep your eye on the prize
and are willing to put in the hard work
that goes with it you'll get what you
want very cool alright well thank you
we've been speaking with TV chef and
comedian Nadia G for more on Nadia
please visit her site bitchin lifestyle
TV on twitter at bitchin kitchen
facebook.com slash bitchin kitchen and
also on youtube at bitchin kitchen
online thank you again Nadia thank you
you're appreciated you very awesome all
right wow that was terrific and then
we're gonna thank all of you for joining
us on yet another
mission of film courage we look forward
to being here with you next sunday at
noon on le talk radio com we're going to
be speaking with bloggers and writer
Jeanne vilette bowerman as well as
writer and Pulitzer Prize winner Douglas
a Blackman you can find out more about
next week's guest by visiting Jeanne v
be calm and slavery by another name com
also many thanks to Ronan rosner here at
la talk radio Rowan and built film
courage calm for us and he runs the
board at the station as well he was
stuck in the elevator today guys you
know and our hurt our hearts sank but
you know he was rescued he's okay cool
collected as Ronan always is you know so
so sudden send you're good you're good
wishes that Sironen here in studio and
until next Sunday have a great week
you